GO OUT AND SUPPORT DAVID MARCUS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEANWHILE STRAIGHT AHEAD, AFTER
NEARLY THREE DECADES ON THE
FORCE, NYPD PRECINCT COMMANDER
JUST QUIT.
OVER IN THE BRONX.
THE REASON IS LEADERS ARE NOW
PLACATING RIDERS WITH MEASURES
LIKE EXPANDING THE PLAINCLOTHES
ANTI-CRIME UNIT, POLICE ARE ALSO
BEING HELD BACK AS FIREWORKS
ATTACKS OR RAVAGING THE CITY.
ONE OF THOSE RECENT FIRE WORKS
ATTACKS INJURED A 3-YEAR-OLD
BOY.
YOU SAY THAT?
BILL de BLASIO HAS BIGGER
CONCERNS.
HE HAS JUST ANNOUNCED HE WILL BE
PAINTING BLACK LIVES MATTER ON A
STREET OUTSIDE TRUMP TOWER.
AN EDITOR AT CITY JOURNAL JOINS
US NOW.
WHAT ABOUT THOSE PRIORITIES FROM
THE MAYOR?
>> THE MAYOR HAS ALWAYS GOT HIS
PRIORITIES STRAIGHT AS YOU WELL
KNOW.
PAINTING BLACK LIVES MATTER IN
FRONT OF TRUMP TOWER BUT THINGS
LIKE THAT, ALL OF THAT IS EASY.
KEEPING NEIGHBORHOODS SAFE,
FIXING SCHOOLS, THAT SORT OF
THING IS HARD.
SO PEOPLE LIKE HIM ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO TRY TO TAKE THE EASY
WAY OUT AND THAT’S WHAT WE’VE
BEEN SAYING.
>> Brian: SOMEONE SHOULD TELL
HIM THAT DONALD TRUMP DOESN’T
WORK THERE NOW.
NUMBER TWO IS MURDERS ARE UP
48%, SHOOTINGS OF REP 86%.
HE DISBANDED THE ANTI-CRIME UNIT
AND HIS BAIL LAWS MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO HOLD ANYONE IN
JAIL.
HIS COMMISSIONER IS BESIDE
HIMSELF, HE PRECINCT COMMANDERS
ARE QUITTING.
THIS IS A CRISIS HE MADE.
>> THIS IS ALL HIS DOING.
THE COMMANDER OF THE 46 PRECINCT
IN THE BRONX APPARENTLY JUST HAD
IT.
SHOOTINGS IN HIS PRECINCT ARE UP
600% OVER LAST YEAR FOR THE LAST
28 DAYS.
THERE’S BEEN DOZENS OF SHOOTINGS
AND WITH THE DISBANDING OF THE
ANTI-CRIME UNIT, THOSE OF THE
GUYS WHO GO AND TAKE GUNS OFF
THE STREET AND NOW THERE’S NO
DIRECTION.
APPARENTLY I’VE HEARD REPORTS
THAT THEY WANTED TO HAVE HIM GO
AND TAKE A KNEE AT THE NEXT
PRECINCT COMMUNITY MEETING AND
HE WAS LIKE I’M NOT DOING IT.
THIS ISN’T WHAT I’M HERE FOR.
WE ARE NOT BEING ALLOWED TO DO
OUR JOBS.
THE COMMISSIONER EVEN HAS SAID
THAT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS IMPLODING IN NEW YORK.
IT IS REALLY LOOKING PRETTY BAD.
>> Brian: WHEN THE
COMMISSIONER SAYS THAT HE WOULD
HAVE CONTROL WHAT THAT TO A
DEGREE, IT’S GETTING SCARY.
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER GROUP IN
CASE YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY
WERE ABOUT, IF THE U.S. DOESN’T
GIVE US WHAT WE WANT, THEN WE
WILL BURN DOWN THE SYSTEM AND
REPLACE IT.
GOOD.
HE CONTINUED TO PAINT THAT IN